what's what's up with this defensive
looting stuff man
because you're talking to a group of
people that have been
that experience that i have with law
enforcement and your experience with law
enforcement
we're not getting that same feeling from
the suburban areas with law enforcement
and if that has been your lived
experience for decades for the length of
you you're not going to come across
police officers for like a bunch
but if you come across them five times
and four of them are trash
and you have no experience of the other
like good officers
so it becomes like yo you got to
remember we don't own these buildings in
the places that we live
yeah but i mean people do so and i get
you
look at that firefighter in uh you know
by the firefighter in minneapolis it was
his dream he saved up all this money
opened a sports bar
and they burned it they set it on fire
he shows up the next day they're
literally stealing his safe as he's
arriving and the news
crews are filming and he's crying he and
they end up launching a gofundme for
this guy
the next day the whole building was
completely demolished the the writers
and leaders came back destroyed
everything
so so let's talk about this it's not the
vast majority of the people from the
community doing this right let me tell
you a quick story
and the reason i bring this up i was in
ferguson when the riots were happening i
got there like
like a day or two after they burned down
that gas station and
when the riots like reignited and this
looting started
a bunch of young black men linked arms
and protected that market
correct and this uh i was i was standing
i was i'm standing right next to these
guys
and i'm with this dude who's uh who was
previously with al jazeera he's now with
uh i believe he's with vice
and he asked them what are you guys
doing why are you linking arms
and he said these people looting don't
live here yep we do
yep these people are taking advantage of
us yes and he's like
but guess what the media is defending
those people correct in defense of
looting
so they're coming from outside they're
attacking these poor people
who are desperate you know what really
really made me angry dude
to see these young men facing down an
angry mob saying
back off it's our store and then all
these these lefty publications party
story saying actually
they were looting to fight back against
capitalism lying
yeah media most effective devil in
america they got a book
a book called defensive lining npr
interviews the author when i say
when i say a few weeks ago i was in i
was in philly i was at copa on 40th and
was that chestnut or something like that
west philly 40th street
as i'm sitting outside having drinks
about 40 or 50
all black antifa start walking past
i'm strapped so i'm good i will light
y'all all the way up if
anything get goofy out here um pa's got
good gun laws right yeah and
and i'm gonna be a legend listen
no i'm like listen i'm like leonidas
it's not
i cannot if i die in defense of freedom
you know how like that's nothing more
honorable to me
valhalla you know what i'm saying i got
oh it's i'm floating in the pearly gates
with
here comes like all of the hot girls of
every universe are coming my way but i
want to make sure we stress right now
you're saying you would die defending it
absolutely killing a bunch of people no
defending it right right and so
um so i'm good i'm confident in my skill
set
um so they're walking and they got on
all black but i'm like it's clearly like
y'all the white dudes totally y'all are
totally white dudes and i said
yo it's no black people out they got the
bats they got the bats
it's like a scene from the purge right
and i'm having my copa cattle like i'm
chilling
and i'm like yo y'all all white we're
the black dudes and it was one dude that
happened to be black he was like we out
here
i'm like no you're out here yeah the
remaining 49
is like suburban white dudes and i said
you're trying to get y'all got that
soros money huh
and literally the dude says we're trying
to another dude says we're trying
to joking though i lied to you not and i
i'm so mad that i didn't think
i didn't want to have a phone in my hand
because they had bats i don't want to
have a phone in my hand if i gotta you
know get busy
so one of the dudes goes over to if i'm
lying i'm flying i swear if y'all
anybody listening
wants to do some independent journalism
allegro's is the pizza shop across the
street
there's one of these dudes with a bat
goes over to the atm thing and starts
trying to hit it
i get up i'm like yo leave it alone
you're not from here you're going to get
my community
i'm not even from west philly y'all
going to get my community called
out for this leave it alone and they
leave and they leave
the people that's doing this come on bro
it's pallets of bricks just conveniently
left at places
so y'all are busting people in the media
debunked
all of that what the pallets of bricks
just conveniently placed
random places that's the same thing as
saying like i got video of it that's the
same thing as saying like
my homies saying yo maj look i'm
facetiming you see this crate of guns in
chicago
no that's not a thing i'm not saying the
media is right yeah i'm saying like yeah
here's what i love right i don't want i
don't want to get sidetracked so we'll
try and lose back but
when uh we had tucker carlson had this
this woman on she's a whistleblower yeah
she said that she worked university of
hong kong she knows that china like
release covet or whatever
tucker crosser had her on and he gets
flagged it's fake news
they they put warnings and blocks on his
on a bunch of his content yeah
and then also the media starts claiming
that he had on a conspiracy theory and
i'm like well
hold on hold on personally i don't
believe it i really i don't believe it
was
like an oblige or anything like that but
who why do we get to choose which
expert is a real expert which expert
isn't who are the fact checkers so i'll
tell you my personal bias
i think you know again i don't want to
derail to covet stuff
i'm like look man if you tell me that
there was a unsanitary market where
they're like got all this really nasty
stuff going on and then
some like virus emerge from it i'm gonna
be like it's a simple solution man it
makes sense
however i do see the problem of the
media in that you can have
trump come out and be like here's a
handful of studies that say this thing
is a good thing
and then the media just says it's not
yeah so the media doesn't get to be the
arbiter of truth simply from saying it
right so that was my point of reference
to the bricks being lying around
everywhere
all they did for the most part was say
oh it's actually not true because we
were told it's not true
right and so i get flagged for stuff
like i posted what
ruth bader ginsburg said in regards to
getting a nominee
for scotus during the last year of the
thing
right right she said it it's not me i'm
not like
fake quoting her you're not mitch
mcconnell you didn't come out right like
complain about merrick garland
no i just quoted what she said
instagram's like oh well this is
partially true because the date
bro cut it out dude cut it out dude dude
they did to me
i tweeted except so when the virginia
giuffray leaks came out about epstein
yeah i tweeted something to the effect
of bill clinton
was in these flight logs and now a
witness has id'd him
as having been on the island this would
be big news journalism is dead it's just
political
advocacy at this at this point somebody
took a screenshot it got like 10
000 12 000 retweets somebody
screenshotted it posted to facebook
where this fact-checking company which
is only a couple guys apparently but
they get this access called it fake
false information yep
and so when i went to the i looked at it
and said here's the fact check the fact
check said everything i claimed was 100
correct
yet they still put the fake tank on it
media most effective devil in america
these are all these are all reasons why
when i go
say things like the brianna taylor
scenario like covet
like this like that the media for a very
long time has been
the arm of whatever political side
of the government so you'll get this
part extreme you'll get that part
extreme
so when law enforcement says oh we
knocked on the door
when when you know uh
law enforcement says oh it wasn't us
that dropped a bomb
in philadelphia on a like residential
block
i don't believe you now if you prove to
me that you're accurate
i'll go eat my hat but and but
believe you this is a ch this is the big
a big ethical challenge too because
so i would say idealistically like when
i take those political compass tests
i'm left libertarian and i get really
offended when people claim antifa is
left libertarian they're not
no the hippies are people chilling on
the farm enjoying the sun and my
own business right and so realistically
though when it comes to policy
i become more of a liberal because i
think we do need more authority
and and i'll tell you what do you mean
by more authority i'm not saying
authoritarianism and i'm not even saying
most authority just a little bit right
so you mean
you mean a little bit more or a little
bit like a
limited government i'm saying uh a
little bit more i think you need a
little bit more authority than
libertarianism
that's my that's my opinion okay and so
the the example
i think that everyone loves to cite is i
don't know if you've ever heard it's
like the the shopping cart problem
that the shopping cart is the perfect
example of
human civilization you use it it's it's
you know the shopping cart is a free
thing for you to use
you get your stuff you're allowed to
carry your stuff to your car and then
all you got to do is put it in the
corral
you got to walk you got to walk 10 feet
but guess what people do they just kick
it
they just just dump it on the ground in
a random spot and they're like
there's no obligation to do it the only
reason you should is because it would be
better for everyone else but people
still choose not to
and so i'm not so here this is a serious
ethical conundrum that i have to think
about is
recognizing like where the lines are in
terms of
when do we say people are too stupid and
or when do we say let them do it
whatever they want
and so to clarify when people were
living
you know very far apart and there were
very few people you have a bigger bubble
of freedom
you have more space right so one of the
reasons i want to move out to the middle
of nowhere where we are now
is that i can go my backyard and i can
set up my archery practice and
everything i've got to worry about
neighbors because there's
nothing around me it's great i watch
these videos of people firing guns and
like
they walk out into their open space and
they've got the the rain set up with all
the dirt and all that stuff and i'm like
you can't do that in a city yeah the
closer you get to other people the more
your bubble starts shrinking
and you're the amount of freedom you get
starts shrinking and it's because we're
desperately trying to accommodate each
other
and then you start stacking laws on top
of laws i think that's the problem
is people live to smash together so i do
agree with that
in in regards to you have to be
whoa sorry bro yeah we got breaking news
what 30 seconds ago
police officer so this is legit where's
this from
luke rudkowski if we are changed just
seated br just tweeted breaking
police officer shot near protest in
louisville kentucky
uh the video we have we have pulled up
oh okay
so it doesn't show anything graphic it's
just a shaky video
people are yelling i don't know what's
going on let's uh i want to be very
careful here this is breaking coming
from luke wrkowski so
what you got to understand whenever it
comes to uh whenever it comes to
breaking news
everybody got to realize information
will change so we're live right now
we're talking about this
and of course we're tracking this
information i'll tell you this is why i
want to live in the middle of nowhere
too dude
yeah but anyway oh i'm out in 2022 i'm
i'm i'm i'm thanos on my planet thanos
you have your garden
but are you gonna kill half the
population before you go to your farm if
i don't have to hopefully not
you're saying so so okay so anyway just
we're going to keep tracking the
breaking news uh little keep an eye on
it
but you uh let's go back to that point
we're talking about liberty authority
how much space you had i agree in that
you ha
you have to be it's like shooting i have
to be more if i have open space
my yosemite sam dude bang bang bang bang
i know that
any direction is it you know more than
likely not a human
or not something that i'm willing to
destroy i know my target and what's
beyond it
you can't do that when there's more
people around so i do agree there
i don't think that your freedom not the
act
of owning guns that doesn't shrink the
where i shoot them because there's more
people around as a safe responsible gun
owner
that does shrink so it's it's this is
interesting i remember
remember remember when they ban
cigarettes everywhere like when they oh
yeah when they started saying you can't
smoke inside bars oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
no not not a no smoking zone but like no
in this whole building
man i remember this because this was
going down in chicago when i was like
i think i was late teens earlier like
early 20s it was like i don't know i
remember
remember how old i was but it was very
it was like around the time obama was
running and stuff so i'm like
i'm this urban liberal i i had my you
know teenage angst punk rock phase and
then i started aged out i became more of
a liberals like obama
but when i heard what they were doing
with banning cigarettes i immediately
was like
why are they banning people from smoking
and they're like oh because it's bad for
you and i was like
so don't go to the bar and they're like
but what if i want to go to the bar then
go to a different bar
and they're like but all the bars allow
smoking i'm like then open a bar that
doesn't
simple but instead they pass a law
banning all restaurants you know what
they did
i was in arizona this is awesome i was
hanging with a friend of mine she was a
bartender
they cut a tiny one square foot hole in
the roof to be classified as outdoors
and i'm like it's the stupidest thing i
ever heard you made them take us
a saw and cut through their roof and now
you're still gonna allow them to operate
like a normal bar it's a dumbest thing
but you know what's beautiful about that
i think so let's go back to that
you made a law that now as a person that
smokes cigars
i smoke cigars if i
smoke this cigar and don't put it out
and then don't leave you'll call a
person with a gun to potentially come
kill me
for smoking the cigar well it's because
inhaling the smoke is i
see i disagree with you guys i used to
work at a bar and
it was i was economically bound to it so
when they couldn't smoke inside i was
able to breathe
my life expectancy went up i'm sure life
my dad used to smoke in the house and it
was just horrible
and my mom made him smoke outside it was
so much better but my aunt and uncle
still smoked in the house
i didn't ever want to go over to their
house it was just disgusting trying to
eat in a restaurant when people were
smoking like across the room go eat
somewhere else you can't
but every restaurant you could smoke at
it was disgusting don't you know
this is i think that's the greatest
thing if that's on you
don't eat out basically it was like if
you don't want to participate in society
or
open a restaurant that says we
don't allow smoking so for example right
liberty the mass is freedom over
everything
that right so you you sorry bro unless
you like the kid that's like
ryan like you're 14 you're not getting
20 million dollars so it's over for you
to 18.
but in that scenario right the
the free market is the answer take the
mask thing
i don't want to wear a mask i
think that this is a sham i think that
it's real because i immediately started
a group chat
with like people that worked in the er
paramedics
virologists people that are way smarter
than me saying hey what it what's going
on what what
what is happening here and they like no
no it's real this is how people are
dying
but media is making it way bigger than
what it is
so early on i was like yep not doing it
i with the mask i agree because i can't
smell it i'm not
physically effect whether i'm told not
physically affected by them i don't know
it's really simple the mask smoke the
mask another world the mask is just so
you don't spin on people right
it's it's or you could just not spit on
people well no no
people don't realize man they they
really don't like
you people talk and spit happens here's
the thing
spit spitting happening it the death
rate now that we have data
right i get in the beginning you're
nervous about
man this is unprecedented cool i'm with
you but then i was at my bunker i was
like
oh this is what we trained for i thought
it was remember how youtube was
snatching off
all of the like people in china were
like just passing out like yeah falling
and then and when it gets snatched off
for youtube i'm like bro
like that was crazy and it was gone
because they couldn't breathe and
they're just falling over
and so i was like i went to my bunker
and i was like
yeah man this might be like the walking
dead this might be it that's what i
thought
well i don't know about the walking dead
but we were like this is it
you're serious man yeah now me i was
like i got too many rounds i'm ready
and so how many rounds per per per uh
per gun they say you should have at
least a thousand per gun i think you
were saying that right that's okay
anyway continue continue so i said let
me wait to the mccluskey's point i was
like
just wait a little bit just wait and see
and i said if i see two people in philly
like drop out oh it's go time
nobody dropped i'm i'm looking at nobody
dying
i'm looking at the the inconsistencies
in the story i had people that worked at
uh hospitals telling me that the cdc was
changing the guidelines
i'm like oh now this is this is trash
this is not there were too many holes in
the story so i made a choice to go yeah
i'm not wearing it
and then i made myself the guinea pig i
went to
all of the hot spots all of them
i've been to miami orlando the
libertarian convention was
in orlando i jet skied i went to texas
like three times i've been to every hot
spot
for new york every hot spot
in america twice since this started
no mask got on airplanes no mask no mass
no matter
the airlines didn't make you do it in
the beginning now they on some like
hey man and i'm like yo this is stupid
right so what i did was
i was like i don't want to argue with
y'all every time i get on a plane
and technically even y'all took a lot of
government bailout money
you technically are kind of a private
entity but you're not
but i'm gonna go get an rv and that's
what i did
this is a really good uh uh discussion
for like liberal versus libertarian
not that libertarians are all like like
liberal typically refers to like a
center left
and the way i view it is if if
uh maybe if i had more faith in humanity
i would just stick to straight up
libertarian idea ideals
i think the mask is a good example of
where we probably disagree my attitude
is just where the mask
like i i hear a lot of people say like
it's you know
why it's not a big deal it's just you
choose your battles you know what i mean
you choose when to fight
i view it kind of like being stealthy
and being
you know uh i don't want to say
subversive
but uh stealthy i guess he's the way to
put it
no one can see me i can move a little
bit easier right right right i don't
wanna i don't i don't wanna start fights
for no reason i wanna make sure that
everything i do is targeted specific and
i'm on a mission
but it's not for no reason do you like
so based on after that it comes out
right the data's come out even the cdc
is like okay bro you got us
well so there there's there's uh there's
political social and
physical reasons right right so i think
right now when you look at the death
rate
there's two perspectives one it's like
we crushed the curve man 15 days to slow
the spread turned into 170 is ridiculous
right this is this now we're just
destroying the economy so why are we
complying with it in a symbolism
symbolistic way no that's the lockdowns
though but that's the the lockdowns are
based on
the masks those are part and parcel so
so if there's a
compliance is in wearing a mask
compliance is you know non-compliance is
dr king going like
because i'm pretty sure there was some
people going first of all the mass thing
isn't this is a rerun
they're the anti-mass people happened
back in the day with polio especially
like in philly yeah
you know what i mean and spanish spanish
flu excuse me i said polio
so the not wearing the mask isn't
that it's not for nothing it's i'm not
complying with something that's not
based in science
it's not what you lied to me about i
disagree
you lie they lied they lied the models
were based on things but
hold on hold on so i think the challenge
is were they wrong
yes so that's that's that's different
from a lie no no no
they they initially the first person you
guys know that this
the guy that over in what was in oxford
that was like
hey this is how many people could die if
we do know that that that that that
right right
and that was the entire model models are
what you use
as predictions when you don't have data
let me see so so they that guy was wrong
they based their number off of that
fauchi
knew mr devious he straight up said
we told people not to wear masks because
we were worried medical professionals
wouldn't be
which is a lie well right exactly
exactly and he keeps lying
so so what we have is the overarching
theme in tonight's episode
is government officials consistently
lying well with the mask
i agree with kind of both you guys i
think it's you don't know whether
they're right or they're wrong so why
are you being forced to do it but when
you're talking about smoking i wanna go
back to smoking because if we want to
talk about government making laws
for people yeah and overreaching i think
this is a system where
if one person wants to screw it up for
everyone else
we have to make laws so that they can't
because people are
selfish and drugs are addictive some
drugs especially nicotine
no this is what got rid of peanuts and
airplanes
you know i used to i take it a little
far but that's what they did because
right too many peanut shells no no
because people were allergic to peanuts
ricky ricky i think it's ricky your
favorite cigarettes
i can't eat peanuts no because the
peanut dust can get in the air and i can
kill somebody
so look man i
i understand maybe the peanut thing
because you got a lot of people allergic
to peanuts and if you're in a closed
cabin with recirculated air
you can die we're basically saying this
group of people can't fly thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for
free if you want to listen to us there
thanks for hanging out and we will see
you all
next time